welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Percy Jackson and the Olympians season 1
meet Percy Jackson Percy being short for
percus the hero from Greek mythology and
Percy has had a difficult childhood
thinking he's crazy because he can see
mythological creatures that no one else
can today his Visions are worse than
ever when his math teacher turns into a
monster and attacks him but his other
teacher had just lent him a pen which
turns into a sword and he slays that
monster naturally though no one else saw
a thing so maybe Percy's finally had a
full mental break but he has a mother
that's and supportive she's like well
Percy guess it's time to finally tell
you Greek mythology is real and your
father was a God yes that's right you're
a wizard Harry well not a wizard a
demigod Percy's best friend Grover comes
over and now that Percy's Eyes Are Open
he notices Grover has goat legs yes he's
a Sader that was specifically assigned
to protect Percy yes demigods or half
Bloods live a life of constant danger
they're magnets for Monsters like the
Minar that's coming after him right now
Percy's mom says goodbye she's staying
behind to distract it while the boys get
to safety and so Percy watches as his
mother is killed Percy fires up his pen
sword and goes to fight the minitar he's
way outclassed but basically gets lucky
and somehow manages to defeat this thing
and so Percy makes it to Camp halfblood
a safe place where demigods can learn to
use their powers the camp director is
dianis yeah the god of wine he's here as
a punishment forced to hang around a
bunch of kids while being totally sober
but really running the camp is Percy's
nice teacher who's actually a centaur
it's Chiron legendary trainer of Heroes
so the campers are divided by which God
is their parent but Percy's father is
still a mystery he won't know till his
dad claims him Percy befriends an older
kid Luke who gives him the lowdown the
campers compete for Glory to win their
parents approval the most Glory comes
from Capture the Flag a full-on ancient
Greek war game Percy's team captain is
Annabeth the Camp's best fighter and
she's got a special mission for the new
kid she puts on her invisibility cap and
vanishes and now the other team
Captain's coming after Percy cuz as the
kid who killed the minitar he's now a
big Target but he was just baited to
lure her away while the rest of the team
captured the flag and they win during
the fight Percy was not doing great but
once he got close to water he got a lot
better and now in the lake his father
claims him it's Poseidon god of the sea
but Poseidon doesn't have any other kids
here turns out Percy is a forbidden
child The Big Three Zeus Poseidon in
Hades made a pack that their kids were
too strong they wouldn't have anymore in
fact Zeus and Poseidon are going to war
because someone stole Zeus's Master Bolt
And as a newly revealed forbidden child
Zeus thinks it was Percy working for his
dad of course Percy didn't steal the
master bolt but to prove his innocence
he's going to have to get it back from
the real supposed culprit the other
brother Hades and Percy has another
reason to visit the underworld turns out
his mom is not really dead the way she
disappeared into sparkling light means
Hades in fact kidnapped her so Percy
Jackson sets off on his quest with his
best friend Grover and his new friend
anabeth though he and Annabeth aren't
friends at first they butt heads and
Grover tries to sing the friendship song
to keep them all working together but
Percy's worried because the Oracle
prophesized that one of his friends
would betray him now at first their
grand Adventure is pretty mundane
they're just taking a bus to Los Angeles
but almost immediately some monsters
show up so yeah they are in Mortal Peril
they come to a rest stop with a ton of
statues yeah you know who lives here
it's Medusa but she's not a monster
she's just a person who the gods cursed
for petty reasons and yeah if you
remember your Greek mythology The
Olympian gods are kind of awful but it's
soon apparent they don't see eye to eye
so Medusa turns on him but Annabeth puts
the invisibility cap on her so Percy can
open his eyes and cut her head off but
Medusa had a valid point the gods were
very unfair to her and so he's going to
ship them her head with which is wildly
impertinent but Percy's kind of an
impertinent guy next our crew hop a
train where they meet AK kidna mother of
monsters who scks a chimera on them so
they're on the run in St Louis luckily
Annabeth's mother has a safe house here
yes the St Louis Arch is a temple of
Athena and Athena could keep the
monsters out but she's mad about the
whole Medusa head thing and is letting
them in as punishment so Percy Jackson's
going to sacrifice himself let his
friends get away while he holds off the
Chimera and the Chimera absolutely
wrecks him Percy Jackson falls to his
death but luckily there's water nearby
and his dad Poseidon steps in to save
him but right now these kids are wanted
criminals so public transportation is
not an option luckily they're picked up
by a motorcycle guy none other than
Aries god of war and Aries thinks their
Quest is dumb Zeus and Poseidon are
going to go to war no matter what
because that's just what gods do but
he'll help them if they retrieve his
shield which is held at H festus's
abandoned amusement park but to get the
shield someone has to sit on the cursed
throne and once again Percy sacrifices
himself and takes one for the team by
now these two have become real close and
so Annabeth's trying to release her
friend at first hesus doesn't want to
let him go but she's like hey why are
you Gods so mean like can't we all just
be better people and this resonates with
aestus who the other gods treat poorly
and so he lets Percy Jackson go so Aries
holds up his end of the bargain and gets
them a ride to Los Angeles well not all
the way to Los Angeles just to Vegas
where then they can ask a ride from
Hermes Hermes hangs out at the Lotus
Casino which like the tale from The
Odyssey if you're not careful you can
forget what you were doing here so they
track down Hermes who at first is not
going to help him Hermes is Luke's
father but Luke hates him because he
blames him for his mom's death Hermes
feels real bad about that but sometimes
us gods are powerless too in the end he
still won't help so Annabeth steals his
car keys meanwhile Grover found another
Sader who forgot what he was doing here
earlier we learned about Grover's side
quest to find Pan the god of nature that
disappeared now this guy remembers he
was looking for pan and he almost found
him here but turns out it was just a
search for Pan video game so hermes's
magic taxi cab will teleport them to Los
Angeles if they can drive it out of the
garage eventually they do and turns out
the back door to the underworld is in an
old water bed store Percy and Friends
try to talk their way in but the living
are not allowed to be here and the
entrance is guarded by cbus the giant
three-headed dog but turns out he's just
a sweet little puppers and they distract
him by playing fetch they got to pass
through the forest of regret where if
you have regrets the tree roots grab you
and pretty soon Annabeth is grabbed by
The Roots what does she regret well
there's a lot of her backstory we don't
fully know but her previous best friend
was a forbidden child of Zeus who got
turned into a tree so Percy and Grover
have to leave her behind while she gets
out with her teleport bead but now
Grover's flying sneakers go nuts they're
trying to pull him into the pit of
tardus they managed to get those shoes
off him but that was weird and now
something even weirder happens in his
backpack pers PCY finds the master bolt
this was the backpack Aries gave him so
they realized Aries stole the master
bolt and now tricked Percy into
delivering it to Hades but they still
have to rescue Percy's mom so they go to
visit the lord of the underworld himself
80s who turns out is kind of a nice guy
he's like wao I didn't kidnap your mom I
rescued her from the minitar so now we
can make a trade but Percy's like no way
man I'm not giving you the master bolt
but turns out Hades doesn't want the
master bolt Hades has no interest in
taking over Olympus he's actually very
happy here in the Underworld he just
wants his helmet of Darkness back which
he thinks Percy stole and then used to
steal the master bolt so Percy realizes
the real big bad is Father of the Gods
Kronos they overthrew him and banished
him to tardus where he's spent eternity
plotting his revenge so first things
first Percy makes the deal I'll get your
helmet in exchange for my mom so Percy
has to get the helmet back from Aries
who is apparently working with Kronos so
Percy challenges him to single combat
which of course he would definitely lose
but he sets the rule if I draw First
Blood you give me the helm back and let
us live yeah that's the God's big
weakness they have to follow certain
rules that's why they have mortal
children who are able to break the rules
for them but these kids can use that to
their advantage and so it's the Percy
and Aries duel once again Percy is going
to lose but luckily Percy always fights
near the water and now he summons a huge
Title Wave which knocks Aries Down long
enough for Percy to draw First Blood
Aries is very mad but he has no choice
he gives them the helm and they give it
to Hades in exchange for Percy's mom but
first they have a bigger problem the war
between Zeus and Poseidon might destroy
the entire world so Percy goes to return
the bolt at the top of the Empire State
Building in the secret elevator to
Olympus and Percy Jackson Returns the
master bolt to Zeus he explains this was
all the master plan of Kronos to trick
them into war and weaken them both but
Zeus doesn't really care he's like oh
I'm going to war beside in anyway just
for fun and so Percy Jackson tells this
guy off which is once again very
impertinent and so Zeus is going to
Smite him but wait what's this Percy is
saved by his father Poseidon and he is
willing to put his ego aside and
surrenders this war before it begins and
that's apparently good enough for Zeus
now he can go deal with Kronos now
finally Percy gets to meet his father
who turns out is a really good guy and
he comes to understand his father really
does love him but couldn't be in his
life because of Godly reasons and so
Percy completed his quest and the day is
saved except it had to be a halfblood
who actually stole the bolt they assume
it was AR's daughter Clarice but Percy
remembers the prophecy none of his
friends ended up betraying him turns out
it was Luke who gave Percy the sneakers
that tried to deliver the bolt to Kronos
Luke explains I'm not a bad guy the gods
are bad so we have to help Kronos
overthrow him but Percy's like hey the
gods are doing their best plus Kronos is
very obviously worse and so Luke and
Percy have a sword fight where once
again Percy is going to lose but Percy
saved by Annabeth who heard the whole
thing and is real mad at Luke who she
considers a brother but Luke escapes
with his portal making sword and that's
a problem for season two and so as
summer camp comes to an end Percy and
Annabeth are going back to their normal
lives while Grover is officially
beginning his search for pan and when
Percy gets home his mother's alive yes
Hades kept his word and mother and son
reunited and that's where season 1 comes
to an end if you like this recap hit
that subscribe button for more of the
best Recaps of TV and
movies